the twins saw alexander last sunday in
detroit and he pitched awfully well
against them in relief of casey mize and
the 2-2 pitch looped into right center
field over scope said there's a basic
single for polanco miguel sono steps to
the plate line drive on one hop to
second base scope to the left of second
will field step on the bag fire to first
and that is a big
double play base is empty and two outs
and the 1-1 a ground ball right side
based at right field so cruz with three
in the left side of second singles to
right
and the twins have their second hit of
the inning 3-2 again swinging a miss
change-up got him away perfect pitch
beautiful he has started three games in
this opener roll we've seen him record a
save also in this season he's kind of
done a little bit of everything
swinging a miss on a breaking ball that
would have been probably a strike anyway
in the outside corner at 80. so scope on
three pitches strikes out now two down
that's the 22nd strikeout for whistler
who's averaging 11 strikeouts per night
02 count to cabrera and the pitch he got
him strike three in a breaking ball
and whistler strikes out two in a one
two three first win rosario didn't play
in the first game leading off the second
inning no score and a 1-1 a swing a line
drive base hit center field so rosario
with a lead off single rather twins have
three hits three singles off of
alexander
swinging a fly ball into the right field
corner bonifacio into the shadows
reaches up makes the catch little snow
cone almost came out of his glove
adrian's a deep drive to right lots of
hard contact in the second inning but
two good plays by bonifacio going back
on deep fly balls so lead off man on
nobody out and now willie castro and the
1-2 pitch a fly ball left center field
towards the alley rosario fighting the
sun and will make the catch front of his
chest for the out and the 3-1 pitch has
popped up this will be playable i
believe yep room for avila fowl
territory near the tiger dugout he's got
it and that's out number two and the
pitch is strike three called in a
breaking ball and bonifacio strikes out
looking the tigers don't score they
leave one top
polanco
circle and a pitch ground ball base hit
and polanco's got a two-hit game a
grounder through the hole nelson cruz
and a ground ball right side nobody
there polanco will hold up at second so
cruz has two base hits both of them to
the opposite field against the lefty
it'll be up now to brent rooker fourth
trip to the plate in the major leagues
he's over two and has been hit by a
pitch
driven to left a base hit polanco
rounding third he's coming home the
throw from stewart is not in time and
brent rooker with his first major league
hit and run batted in well
congratulations to him that that's a
moment he'll never forget a long time
comment for him reyes who's in a fly
ball to center one nothing our score
here in the third
victor reyes hits a ground ball up the
middle and pass to diving gonzales in
the center severe jam job and somehow
that ball got through the infield and
now it's going to be jonathan's scope
tying run it first twins up one nothing
jonathan scope swings and hits a fly
ball right field coming over and diving
not making the play as rooker it's going
to get into the corner that's going to
score reyes
rooker doe for didn't have a chance at
it reyes scores from first and jonathan
scope all the way to third a line drive
into the right field corner rbi triple
for a scope and the tigers have tied it
at one here in the third
he did he went to right with it and
that's gonna drop in front of booker and
jonathan scope comes trotting home the
tigers have the lead an rbi single from
miguel cabrera base is loaded steward at
the plate and here's the pitch it's
strike three right down broadway boy
stewart did not swing the bat with the
basement
peanuts characters that were in the
champions club were taken down because
the reflection the reflection was
bothering the the fielders son will be
happy he's got a peanut allergy so
that's good the 2-2
swing and a miss he got him with a
cutter in and tyler alexander slaps his
hand into his glove beautiful pitch he's
fired up
with two hits will lead things off slap
to left in a three-hit game for polanco
the lead-off man is on again here in the
fifth inning the one-two pitch swinging
the ground ball to third base scooped up
by paredes down to the second one
scope's related first they double up
cruz ending ending 5-4-3 double play
terrific job by brian garcia against
some dangerous hitter yeah good job kept
the ball down keep it in the ballpark
tigers have runners at the corners one
out here in the fifth and a pitch and
that one's popped up should be playable
on the infield it is
so no
stagger around and so no makes the catch
but not pretty and a ground ball should
be it adrianza he'll take the out at
second base to force out cabrera there a
couple of hits couple of runners left on
and now you have two on nobody out and
the batter will be polanco
base head right center field andreyanza
around third he'll score the tying run
on polanco's fourth hit of the afternoon
here's marwin who snapped an old for 16
with a single in the sixth and the
pitcher ground ball up the middle
towards center field and through austin
deal is going to round third it's
bobbled by hill in center throw to
second not in time and the twins take
the lead two away and that'll bring up
castro and the payoff pitch a swag and a
miss he struck him out and down to a
knee
goes castro at 98 may strikes down three
and the twins beat the tigers in eight
three to two to sweep this doubleheader